ensuite avec benoît murat fioles
président de l'association acer bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur rt france pour commencer l'arabie
saoudite a donc nié un ces attaques
notamment celle contre une prison tenue
par des rebelles houthi qui a fait 70
morts une attaque on le rappelle qui
intervient aussi quelques jours après
celle à abou dhabi revendiquée par les
outils dans ce contexte il ya peu de
doutes sur les hauteurs du raid
meurtrier
oui et c'est une technique que les avis
et vous dites
après ce systématiquement lorsque ils
ont bombardé les choses lorsqu'ils ont
bombardé les hôpitaux lorsqu'ils n'ont
pas bombarder les centres névralgiques
de production d'eau ils ont toujours
eu cette
tactique de refus de considérer qu'ils
étaient responsables de ces
bombardements là on l'a bien vu dans
votre reportage il y a quand même une
disproportion absolument scandaleuse
dans le fait de condamner les attaques
des outils le texte est très clair
en condamnant des attentats terroristes
donc ce qui l'est c'est injuste il ya 33
civils qui ont été tués suite à l'
attaque des outils abou dhabi et là il
ya 100 morts et plus d'une centaine de
blessés et
le conseil de sécurité ne condamne pas
dans les mêmes termes puisque là on peut
considérer que c'est un acte de
terrorisme d'état ne condamne pas dans
les mêmes termes les bombardements de la
part de l'arabie saoudite
comment est-ce que vous l'expliquer
parce que l'on est nu c'est vrai qu'ils
condamnent qui demande également une
enquête comment est ce que vous vous
comprenez cette différence
d'appréciation que ce que vous venez
nous nous nous dire
il ya il ya une la population yéménite a
complètement disparu aux yeux des cinq
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité dont la france mais aussi la
grande-bretagne les etats-unis la russie
et la chine puisque ils ont la
possibilité de mettre un veto sur des
déclarations où ils ont ils ont bien
entendu une grande influence sur ce type
de déclaration donc ça c'est le premier
le premier point il ya un travail de la
part des émirats arabes unis et de
l'arabie saoudite qui sont co leaders de
cette coalition et qu'ils sont
responsables de graves crimes de guerre
crimes contre l'humanité comme nous
l'avons montré dans un rapport
nous avons sorti le 10 décembre 2010
2020 et pour l'instant il n'y a pas un
état qui se dressent pour dire cela
suffit maintenant il faut arrêter cette
guerre est le meilleur moyen d'arrêter
cette guerre c'est bien entendu
d'arrêter de vendre des armes il ya
effectivement cette question de
livraisons d'armes
notamment à l'arabie saoudite la france
est concernée d'ailleurs
oui la france est largement concerné les
en 2021
les autorisations je crois que c'est un
peu plus de 31 milliards d'euros
d'autorisation d'exportation d'armes en
direction de tous les pays de la
coalition dont l'egypte donc les émirats
arabes unis et puis la jordanie le
koweït notamment
la france vient de signer enfin le
gouvernement français parce que ça ne
concerne pas quand même la france le
gouvernement français a signé un contrat
de 80 rafale est également 12
hélicoptères de combat airbus un caracal
en direction du gouvernement des émirats
arabes unis alors que l'on sait qu'il
est lui aussi impliqué dans des actes de
torture dans des crimes de guerre et
crimes contre l'humanité ses racines ses
rafale français vont possiblement être
utilisé pour la guerre au yémen
il ya du matériel français qui est
utilisé dans le gard veillée même
puisqu'il ya les avions ravitailleurs
mrtt a330 d'airbus qui les avions qui
ont bombardé aujourd'hui
afin qu'ils ont bombardé par d'hier les
prisons sont ravitaillés par sept avions
ravitailleurs
dont l'autorisation d'exploitation a été
délivrée par le gouvernement français
donc le gouvernement français est
complice de crimes de guerre et de
crimes contre l'humanité et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons saisi le
tribunal administratif en 2018 pour que
pour la suspension de tous les
transferts d'armes en direction de tous
les pays de la coalition pour arrêter
cette que cette complicité qui engage la
france le gouvernement français quand il
s'engage au cette guerre engage la
france donc nous citoyens français il y
a donc depuis 2015 des milliers de
civils qui sont décédées à cause de ce
conflit quelle est la situation
humanitaire sur place le yemen le yémen
manque de tout
williams a demandé de tout à la fois
parce que
les pays de la coalition dirigée par
l'arabie saoudite et les émirats arabes
unis ont organisé un blocus blocus qui
fait partie de crimes de guerre et
crimes contre l'humanité iliad est
parfois dénoncé par les nations unies il
attaque également les moyens de
subsistance de la population civile en
bombardant je voulais dire les champs
les pêcheurs les centres de soins les
hôpitaux ce qui fait que l'évaluation
parce que c'est extrêmement difficile
d'avoir des chiffres précis mais
d'évaluation des nations unies c'est
près de quatre cent mille morts en
décembre 2021 nous sommes aujourd'hui à
peu près à plus de 2400 80 jours de
guerre et les gouvernements qui se les
cinq membres du conseil de sécurité
continue de couvrir cette guerre est de
ne pas faire pression et notamment sur
alors les états unis avaient un moment
ralenti leurs exportations d'armes en
direction des deux pays
arabie saoudite et émirats arabes unis
mais il semblerait que
la nouvelle administration byden
ne ne tiennent pas véritablement ce
point de vue la france et la grande
bretagne continuent sans aucune retenue
de vendre des armes qui sont utilisés
pour la plupart dans la guerre inhumaine
en quelques mots on arrivera au terme de
cette interview est ce qu'il ya des
perspectives de négociations aujourd'hui
entre le gouvernement yéménite et les
rebelles houthis
oui il y aurait si les médias notamment
en france si les ong les grandes ong
internationales
si les églises comme ça se passe
beaucoup en italie mobiliser la
population civile la population on sait
bien que quand la société civile est
mobilisé et bien les états le changent
leur politique
or aujourd'hui les grandes ong
internationales
font rien sur la garonne yémen ou pas ou
pratiquement rien qu'à part quelques
pétitions mais quand il a été il s'est
agi de mettre en place le traité sur le
commerce des armes ces ong
internationales mobilisées tous les mois
la population en france que les plus
calmes et heureusement merci beaucoup
benoît à murat fioles d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur rt franc je le
rappelle vous êtes le président de
l'association à ce